just like when i first told my dad i
wanted a box so what do you want to box
nectarine beaches what do you want
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg hi oh my
god
thanks for our sponsor medterra
the craft trusted effective and
accessible cbd products that support
deeper sleep relaxation and relief go to
medterra
r r m-e-d-t-e-r-r-a dot com
slash omg high and enter the code omg h
i a checkout for 30 off and free
shipping on your first
order listen
no product gets on this podcast without
the
approval of the endorsers
yep
all i asked you was to just pay
attention this week pay attention
all right
so hey this is a this is a small segment
that's the first first one i like to
call [__] tv
[__] tb this is a tv this is a segment a
brand new segment you're here for the
first for the first one the inaugural
version [__] tv
ready aaron
it's very short
i've been watching barry for the last
day [__] amazing
as as detectives and crime fighters
you'd love it have you seen it no i
haven't seen it no [__] hey how is it
that's great [__] amazing what is it
barry barry on hbo okay it's about a
dude that ends up being a hit man but he
go comes out to hollywood to like a
low-rank hitman they hit a dude
and he ends up walking into an acting
class and he just starts taking that
it's [__] crazy starting
um is it similar get shorty was uh
travolta came from miami
and he came to uh
see uh gene hackman
they [__] beat his ass up yeah for
the movie
god
did you see that one that's great i got
him bosh last time it was
[__] blue he wouldn't [__] rub my
[__]
face
[Music]
you know what i don't like about bob she
said you got to watch bosh i know this
girl that's in it
uh you know when you're married but the
husband you know is putre you know if
if he had one choice of choice a or
choice b
he'll take the [__] cotton every time
so uh
she's in it but then bosh when it starts
it's like the [__] starts to talk
spanish like bad like
tusmanos yes i [__] click they don't
have that [__] on uh barry that's why
it's called [__] bosch and [__] tv thank
you now
introduce our guests for today well
let's welcome them with a tight shirt up
there if you and i even if they made the
biggest shirt we'd put on we [__]
look like that this is actually a double
x i mean i can't what am i supposed to
do wait don't don't apologize for being
in shape to us
all right today we've got mike rodriguez
long time friend
uh has been on the long time friend long
time long time franny he was a member he
is still a working member of the los
angeles county sheriff's department he's
currently assigned a homicide bureau
where he's been for the last year are
you one of those dudes 18 years that
[__] pound saga
just kidding i don't even know what
you're talking about i was just pushing
they didn't see anything the [__]
ears got red on the top just on the top
they were like
they could go oh no so so you're
currently
yes uh-huh yep sheriff's homicide 18
years has there been a show a tv show
about about l.a sheriffs
not bosh no that's about my monster
those are probably uh what's bosh uh
animal regulation lapd oh that's what i
mean animal regulation
the i had a joke that i used to say uh
well i used to do the thing i said hey
lapd use the white tees sheriffs use uh
the uh the black tees on the back and
high patrol use the red ones the ladies
[__] you got the golf tournament
i would move it around depending on who
which one of them were there more oh
there you go i finished go ahead okay
well i first left
but what but is this
does he have to do being here as your
friend or as a as a guest can he be both
do you want me to [__] hate him
no i mean i'm sure it's easier to do the
uh
no but you don't have to no he's just
got my mondo
do the
the actual qualifications and then at
the end you say and he's been my friend
for the last
[__] year and a half or i don't know
how long you guys known each other
all right anyways
he's been on the department los angeles
county sheriff's department 30 34 years
he's the last 18 he's worked sheriff's
homicide he was formerly a boxer for the
uh
sheriff's department boxing team that
sheriff's department don't have a boxing
team here because they'll be just
it used to be an annual thing
uh lapd versus sheriff's department the
fire department got involved we brought
guys from new york out here
we take a team down to uh
i asked you a question marine corps
peddled it did canelo alvarez bite off
more than he could chew by fighting that
russian absolutely you know i work with
beavo i was that dude okay okay so if
any if explain who this guy is okay in
case people because i've never seen the
dude before but you know i love boxing
but you know as your life goes you don't
really get a chance to watch what i
always tell people is people canelo is a
great fighter what's this guy's name the
russian guy mitri bivol
well people don't realize he was a
highly decorated amateur worldwide he's
been a world champion for five years i
got a phone call six years ago says mike
will you go to moscow russia you're
going to work a world title fight with
one of freddie roach's guys i work with
all of freddie roberts sure you weren't
over there peeing on the bed going with
with other people well they actually put
me up in a brothel that's where i stayed
for this place
and instead of telling me what i could
eat food they just said hey whatever you
want go ahead and you didn't see like an
eye in the [__] painting like that
a putin like moving like they do in the
old
mystery you know when you're like
probably when you're like this and then
you go i think about a little better the
eye goes like that yeah it's like those
old uh
those old paintings my grandparents used
to have it was i
used to follow you they used to like
because you know they like to
you know put cameras and sound in there
well yeah that was the communist country
over there but anyway
it was really no surprise to us that he
won people kept saying oh canelo and you
got to remember the whole canelo fandom
i mean it's a big deal it's like when
oscar used to fight it's a huge deal
but when i say bit off more than he can
chew this was a legitimate light
heavyweight world champion and i'm gonna
i'll say it yeah he probably bit off
more that he could chew with bivol
because this guy is a great fighter he's
got a high pedigree and if they fought
again he probably beat canelo's ass
again okay so the p if people don't know
like like i've been around boxing a long
time and i've never heard of this guy
how long has he been he hasn't lost
right no he's under there's nobody
that's going to beat i think that
there's nobody that's going to beat this
guy if
if he's already he probably trains in a
brothel if he if he can do all that and
and because he was you saw that fight no
he was
i mean i would go out to training camp
out in india he was training he was
training out in india i'd go out there
once or twice a week to watch him train
because you know just to kind of get a
feel of you know what's going on with
him and his trainers and stuff because
i'm the cup man
and i'd worked with him before so it was
a good match he's a great fighter you
speak english yeah he actually speaks
pretty decently okay so if this guy
if this guy wanted to be
i mean he he's pretty much all business
too he's not like a
a guy that likes to look at for
attention outside the ring no those
russian fighters over there because of
where they come from they're they're all
business but they might not be that big
in the united states but around the
world that guy if he walks down the
street he's probably i mean he's a
national hero in russia he's like
russell peters like russell peters could
could light himself on fire in front of
the comedy store nobody would know him
but if you but if you see him uh in
india or in australia or saudi arabia or
in london i mean everybody knows who he
is russell's actually a friend and met
him through a mma fighter kung li
russell could you describe him or yeah
because i've actually been to his house
and he had my dad his
i don't know a girlfriend you didn't get
that shirt from him though because he
wears shirts i got shirts that are kind
of tight that don't fit no i got this
from gil oh you did yeah this was gill's
shirt in 1988 1981 81
all right so so um
but this dude this dude is like the real
deal the real deal and is he comfortable
at that weight yeah he's a natural he's
not going to go down and wait no
actually he says he could go down one
weight class to the super middleweight
where canelo's probably the at his best
and you know in money talks money talks
because he he [__] still told me
today i was going to get something from
manscape today and i was going to get
some water you probably got some i don't
know how your wubbles are but leave me
while you're getting home they'll be
they'll be begging you for this stuff so
so
um
he pretty much had his way with canelo
in that fight huh i i think he did i
mean he didn't like take him to the
movies and like take him out to red
lobster three times he he went down his
top like on the first day he knew what
was good he knew that canelo couldn't
beat him it was crazy about the sixth
round
we're in the corner and we're talking to
him and he looked up at us and he says i
got this no problem
yeah so you know right yeah and and
boxing is a is a
is a sport where
i mean you know in baseball they go okay
you know it's not over until it's over
but in boxing you could you see a dude
that gets knocked down twice three
knockdown rule the dude gets up and he's
just starts to whatever instinct that is
in a fighter and he just starts throwing
and he hits the dude and knocks the dude
i mean it's really one of those things
where you you look like you could be
navigating pretty well and then you're
in the dressing room and they're cutting
your gloves off what the [__] i had a
fighter that did that we took him back
to the locker room and he says
when do i fight and i say player it's
over
it's over what what punch does that like
to the chin or the side of the head you
know it really just depends it's usually
the george is usually the punch you
don't see
you know the punch you don't see is the
one that hurts you i don't you know you
get you get hit and if you can brace
yourself for it maybe you can you can
lessen the blow but the ones you don't
see you know you remember you did you
see a lot of great knockouts when tommy
hearns knocked out roberto duran you
know in the 80s that was a bad knockout
and duran you know my favorite fighter
i've had a chance to meet him but tommy
hearns was no joke in the 80s and durant
was just too small for tommy hearns it's
small yeah real real small so um and
that punch like herns was right here and
that punch came from like like from left
field it came from like where the luxor
is now yeah way down yeah and he didn't
he hit him
right there and you remember duran when
duran fell actually fell face first i
was working during the day and i made a
bet for a hundred dollars that of course
a latino you better open up if roberto
fought today right i would still put
money on him right even though he's not
going to win and everybody's like
tommy's going to kick his ass i said
hundred dollars this is i was working
during the day
[__] durant hadn't hit the mat yet
[__] phone right
big old loud ring on the old phone that
big phone my grandma i don't know how we
got it we had a we had a ringer outside
sound like an auto shop duster yeah like
an auto shop my grandparents had that
because they were deaf
yeah
and they would be like [__] three
houses i see your [__] phone
like loud [__] really yeah my
grandparents said i want to sell it
thing like this that sounds like i was
in a metal shop yeah
so the long cord
yeah the long cord yeah um
so so
what's are they gonna fight again
i think eventually they will but
canelo's gonna fight triple g in that
third fight which is a good fight for
boxing
i thought triple g won the first fight i
thought he did win the first fight i
have no problems with it being to draw
the second fight um i think
before canelo lost to bevol everybody
was counting triple g out triple g just
beat a guy in japan a couple months ago
that was a really good fighter knocked
him out so i think this third fight is
going to be good for both of them you
know to kind of finish unfinished
business and i think it's going to be
good for boxing bivol's probably going
to he's going to have a couple of fights
and i'd love to see him in canelo again
you know would you would you consider
like they always say that it's like a
car you know when a car gets in a bad
accident and they total them usually but
if they don't that car is never the same
right and they say that about boxers if
a boxer takes a tremendous ass kicking
where they throw the towel in or if he
still has his hands up but he's being
punched and and they come in and break
it up and he loses and for anybody
that's been divorced you know what that
feels like right oh yeah yeah uh yeah
because
one day you got money and the next day
they're cutting your gloves off and
you're going can't wait to go have some
steak
you can't afford it
so so
but uh
a dude's never the same a guy that gets
his ass you know i always tell people
this and it's honest it's it's true it's
almost better to get knocked out with
one punch then today then to sustain an
ass whooping for 10 11 rounds that
really does damage to your body long
term it's like an nfl cornerback they
get burned on a play they got to come
back and they got to have a short memory
right and when you saw when pacquiao got
knocked out by marquez he had a short
memory because it was just really one
punch the rest of their fights had all
been competitive it's when you start
having long-term beatings those are the
ones that put a lot of miles on the
odometer okay now also you know manny
pacquiao was called like the executioner
you know he kicked mexican fighters
so in their fights i think that was the
fourth one or third fourth so so
uh from oscar and all that you know
that
marquez knew that in the last part of a
round he's gonna have his hands down
like that was intel right like in
knowing and watching pacquiao well they
had fought so many damn times they knew
and he didn't know what round but he
knew that
in the last
when they do that [__]
that there was going to be an
opportunity
to take that shot and marquez is a very
smart fighter and he and he took it and
[__] laid his ass out yeah and you
know what's crazy is
i got to work with manny the last part
of his career and he's just he's the
best to work with when he actually won
the title he won the title again after
that a lot of people don't remember that
yeah when he beat keith thurman
in vegas i was actually his cup man for
i was cut man for the last two fights
yeah i mean only eight division world
champion ever it was an honor because
he's not just a guy like oh he was a
champion i mean he's an iconic he was a
yeah he uh he was a one of very few
people that could you know like somebody
say when an actor can open a movie
absolutely he can hold yeah he can hold
vegas for that weekend
those are although
oscar was like that canelo was like that
mayweather you know there's very few
people that could do that uh um
jim gray the reporter i played jim a lot
of the fighters i played golf with him
he said that i said who wouldn't you
want to get hit by we were playing golf
and i said like ernie shavers or you
know one of those guys and he goes i
think canelo is like one of the hardest
hitting dudes
he does especially for his size because
he's not a heavyweight right but there's
an old saying muhammad ali it's a i love
the old 70s 80s boxing muhammad ali said
that if ernie shavers could take a punch
he would have been heavyweight champion
of the world forever he goes that's how
hard ernie shavers hit hard remember
when he hit larry holmes it almost
looked like a gunshot hit him i don't
know how holmes got up right but he did
but he did
remember when all those snipes knocked
down larry holmes and larry looks like
he's getting ready for work come on what
got up he was like trying to put buckle
[__] he was all [__] his leg was
behind and he got up but do you remember
all of his [__] he was champ he knew
his whole life was going to change he
didn't get up oh yeah and he [__]
knew and his face was all do you
remember what happened to snipes after
the fight when they were cutting the
gloves off for the interview
his trainer accidentally
cut his artery oh [__] instead of the
glove he cut into the artery it was
right there on abc with howard cosell
and everything wow yeah he got he had to
take him to the hospital yes but i
remember when all those snipes yeah so
so okay so we'll look forward to do you
think you think that uh
was canelo stalling out triple g to get
to let him get old i mean i mean it's a
there's a business side to it i think
that's why mayweather and pacquiao
didn't fight i think mayweather was
waiting out
pacquiao for a while you know these guys
are smart businessmen all you when you
look at the last 20 years when you look
at these fighters they're great fighters
but they're smart businessmen
oscar oscar never ducked anybody people
talk a lot of [__] about oscar about his
lifestyle and stuff let me tell you
something he fought what do you mean his
lifestyle well you know just because
he's been in the tabloids a little bit
and you know you know what i mean
maybe once or twice
um but but i mean he was a he was a
great fighter he never ducked anybody
no what hap what happened when he fought
trinidad did his corner time to stop
punching that he had it won you know
what that that's that's the one that you
really don't get the answer yeah you
never you know i think maybe they
thought he had to fight one big on
rounds i think so and sometimes when
you're in that corner your perception's
a little bit different
than what maybe the judges are saying
would you tell a runner to to not run as
hard toward the end they're like hey you
got him i just don't you don't have to
run so hard you'd run to the end right i
wouldn't because every round you got you
every to me you want to win every round
especially at that level trinidad's a
great fighter and then what if what if
you go and you're [__] like they tell
you in the seventh hey man you got this
dude you take eight and nine off ten
you need those [__] rounds you gave
them up that comes back and wins three
four rounds in a row momentum like in
life when the momentum changes it's hard
to get it back in golf we'd see a dude
like like that you see a guy leading by
maybe one or two or whatever five they
said it's hard to play with a lead
because
human nature is to play
like you don't want to lose instead of
playing like you're gonna you never
wanna play to lose start to play where
you're holding on or the dude catches
the dude from behind by shooting 64 or
the other guy shot 70. he goes hey i'm
not embarrassed you shouldn't fall out
the guy's not 64 you could have shot 67
you would have beat him but those guys
played conservative from the beginning
and then
like in boxing or what you have where
you have it in your hands like golf you
start playing like safe
and then when you need it toward the end
you you forgot what it was like to
[__] start there's a whole sports
stance paralysis by analysis that's it
you start you start nutting up a little
bit you see it happen i mean you see it
in basketball games teams are leading by
25. you should turn the tv off you turn
it back on half an hour later and it's
tight you know what the in
in golf
if you see it if you see a chick on a
golf course you could see [__]
janierino hey with a [__] golf up
every giant arena
yeah and she's an ugly one she was one
of the one on baywatch
she's the one that wants to go get the
elia and gonzalez
oh i
you put her in golf clothes
and they look how you could put eileen
ryan hey from granny from beverly
hillbillies it's a [__] visor with a
little squirty black [__] and granny and
she was only like 35 when she did that
show right so if you see a girl at a
boxing match isn't she hotter than she
is outside like there's something about
a woman at a boxing you got to remember
those dresses they're like little socks
like a bondigas they're like little
sausages then when you take the dress
off [__] yeah
yeah
yeah you got the menudo the whole thing
it used to be a regular
at the olympic auditorium a group of
guys we schooled when it was
korean church say you want to go back
and see it this is what i wanted the
height of the box we'd go every week
group of guys and my wife
the wives got together and they wanted
to go and i said hey
this is not a place for ladies you know
to go down there she says i see a group
of ladies here everybody said okay let's
go they're not necessarily ladies yeah
no they're not so i said okay we go but
i'm telling you chivalry's dead you know
that that's not a place really you want
to go we go so if the fights are no good
in the ring back they're gonna be good
and they're gonna be good up in the
stands so here come the chingasau so
here comes the guy flying down he comes
here everything every and so she's let's
go i said no we're not going i just
pushed him back up go ahead they said
adam up there she want to go to the
restroom i said you better get some of
your girls to go with you because i
ain't going with you do you remember
what they used to do when they were
unhappy with the decision yeah they
don't they'd throw coins coins they
would piss in a beer cup and throw the
piss in the air well i got a story i
worked with chad
like they just don't care i worked with
chavez jr a couple years ago in tucson
yeah and the fans thought that he quit
yeah so it's me
right freddie roach and chavez jr on the
apron
all of a sudden [__] starts flying some
girl throws a high heel hits me in the
shoulder now she's walking around with
you know could you probably have fat
ankles anyway yeah because you could
just tell that that was a shoe hot where
you picked that up no that shoe looked
like it had that stress test like it was
about to burst anyway like a little
[__] commander yeah it was like it
was like a gill hat
so uh we got hit with everything yeah
did he quit what was the thing there no
no he had busted his nose but the fans
didn't know that he had busted his nose
really bad and he couldn't breathe
and uh but the fans didn't know that
they just figured he quit
but did he say did he say i can't
breathe
well in the corner you could just tell
he couldn't breathe every time he every
time he breathed the only thing was
coming out of his nostrils in his mouth
was that red blood it's dangerous
yeah very dangerous but they don't know
that they're drunk they're just they
just want you know people to fight
but we got hit with everything out here
with a high heel we got hit with cups
what was that at the casino outside no
that was that uh where the suns play in
tucson america west arena i don't know
what they call it now did you go to
fights at seizures when they had that in
the parking lot out there no i remember
watching him though that was back in the
that was in the eighth it was some great
fights there great fight i remember when
stevie cruz beat barry mcguigan in that
fight barry mcguigan was the best
fighter one of the best fighters in the
world he's from ireland
he comes out and fights a kid from fort
worth texas in the 120 degree heat at
caesar's palace he wilted is stevie cruz
still alive he is and i've been trying
to find stevie cruz i've been trying to
get it get him tickets whenever i go to
fights in dallas fort worth i'm going to
be with virgil ortiz um august 6th in
dallas fort worth hey stevie cruz yeah
tell me which one's your camera right
there down stevie cruz man if uh reach
out to somebody that knows me you can go
on my my instagram at boxer rods
b-o-x-e-r-r-o-d-z i want to give you
some tickets to a fight when you fought
at the 81 nationals up in concord
california you came to our gym for all
week
and we kind of hosted the nationals and
i got to know him and i hadn't seen him
since he went on to win the nationals
win a world title last i heard he was
working just you know lives a very
simple life now but he was a great
fighter great fighter um
yeah man he was he was great that fight
they did fight outside and you know that
they did find a lot of fights outside
and um
barry mcguigan
was amazing was an amazing fight he ran
into a dude that that was his night but
do you remember when toward the end of
the of the rounds and barry mcguigan was
saying to his corner say prayer
say a prayer and i was like
say a prayer for me because it's [__]
like well he's from ireland i mean
say a plan say a prayer stevie cruz is
from fort worth texas i would have to
say in july or august in fort worth
texas it gets a little hot gets a little
humid vegas in the summertime is very
hot and i don't think mcguigan really
accounted for that heat
no i think he thought that he was going
to walk through him
longer than he thought i think that's
where
dooku kim and uh ray massini and raymond
senior yeah absolutely
absolutely in the 80s i mean that was
such an unfortunate incident but the 80s
were just such a great era for boxing
everybody fought you never heard of a
guy saying i'm not fighting him he
fought he felt till he died literally
and then his mom
uh
committed suicide as well like did she
couldn't do couldn't deal with the loss
oh wow i didn't know that but
you know it depends man like you know
there's some people that i don't think
there's there anymore but
if you
you mean you guys were in a profession
where you would take a bullet for each
other absolutely you would you would
stay out there till the you wouldn't say
matt it's getting [__] i gotta get the
[__] out of here and that's where like
that guy
and the honor of his sport like he he he
knew what he was doing he could have
quit he and you know what he even
i don't know i think it's an unknown
story he even wrote on the mirror in his
dressing room
i will i will die if i had korean i will
die if i have to and then he meant that
i mean he shouldn't it shouldn't have
came to that
that's just boxing i lost a fighter
three years ago patrick day they did a
feature on hbo he fought in chicago um
he got knocked out in the ring never
regained consciousness those kind of
things will uh
will change you forever both of his
parents were very educated they worked
at the united nations he had a college
degree but he was a good boxer he wasn't
like you know some guy that was just on
the fringes of it he was a highly
decorated amateur he was having a good
pro career not a great fighter but a
good fighter and i remember when he got
hit guys i remember
all i wanted to do was see some movement
and i ran around the ring because i've
seen guys get knocked out and they
rushed to paramedics and immediately
and i saw no movement
and i still had two fights to work
and i'm on the phone with this with it
with his trainer
and i'm like is he okay
and he's like no he's not okay
the worst possible scenario what was the
scenario that he got hit i think when he
got hit his head his head hit the canvas
oh i saw that yeah but you know in
boxing it's not like basketball or
football where your knee hurts and you
can say you can see the swelling you
can't see
what's going on in somebody's body
internally and you got boxers cliff
divers
downhill skiers auto racers those guys
are rosso's little rice rocket those
little those motorcycles i mean it's
sometimes it's not a matter of if
it's a matter of when right those are
dangerous jobs
and getting back to what you said about
you know like you know you're in the
military correct deal i was in the
military and you're a cop i wasn't going
to go that kiss
i remember that yeah comic book was real
bloody yeah i remember that called it
too from me yeah you wanted to be paul
stanley or peter chris what would that
want to be um h freely
i can't remember man probably you wanted
to be gene simmons with your tongue but
i know paul stanley i know those dudes
yeah good dudes yeah
medterra was founded by a group of
friends passionate about bringing cbd to
those who love it most
if you haven't heard of cbd it can
promote relaxation sleep
and a slew of other benefits tropicals
like the hemp infused manuka cream and
on-the-go pain relief roll-on help you
balance your skin and body and mind
tasty sweets like their full-spectrum
deep sleep gummies supports your journey
in finding sleep
restorative sleep that leads to
rejuvenated day you know modern life is
so busy that we often put
a recovery and rest last because there
just isn't enough time but also you know
when you find a product like metera that
can help you go to sleep but also get
deep sleep or like the cream you know
we're big we're big proponents of the
cream that
you know it may take something like the
30 off to lead you to buy these to buy
these products but when you do buy the
products
um they will help you
for as long as you use the products of
it hopefully it's you know during your
life you know so matera has designed
high quality accessible and easy to
incorporate wellness solutions like the
manuka cream and pain relief roll on to
support
daily wellness like you know when i was
uh
doing this last movie that i was
involved with i had some i had some pain
and i used uh some of the product and it
made me it made it easier for me to get
through my day like i'm i'm worried
about
the night time
because you know you're going to rest on
the nighttime but these things help you
get through the day when you're in pain
during the day and it doesn't look like
you're not going to get home for a while
so you know people
have daily pain and you use this stuff
and it helps you get
better rest it helps to relieve the pain
full spectrum deep sleep gummies are a
sweet and simple way to help you fall
asleep faster stay asleep longer and
wake up feeling refreshed so here's the
thing with the
the gummies like some most of the people
that i know
would smoke
before they went to bed
right but i'm more comfortable like i'm
not against this stuff and you and i are
not big users that's right but if people
think i am but we're but we're not big
users but
you had great results with the gummies
right i sure did help you sleep and and
i would prefer to
do the um
the cbd thc
gummies as proposed to smoking like you
know when you're in the house or
whatever the thing it's just it's just a
choice
exactly it's cool to have the choice
yeah our industrial hemp is grown in
america and is us hemp authority
certified our products are third-party
tested
non-gmo contains organic ingredients and
green free omg hi listeners get 30
percent off free shipping with their
order of medterra
go to mitera.com
omghi and enter the code omgh at
checkout
that's medterra.com
omghi
and please enter the code of omghi at
checkout for 30 off and free shipping
but let me let me say this you know
there's a lot of ads and things that
people do other ads but
if you're
younger or older if you're younger
you're probably more aware of what's
going on with cbd and thc but you know
people that are a little bit older that
it's new to them
i think it's something that if they
found this they'd be less reliant on
prescription medication and more relying
on this that they can trust and it's not
as hard on your body as prescriptions
that's what i say
simple i've tried it it works and it
will and you were not a big
expert i was not one to jump into this
stuff due to my background
but this helps allows me to sleep as old
as i am i think i deserve to have a good
night's sleep you know what yeah i think
you're right you know i was having some
trouble you know over the weekend and i
golfed and you get home and you know you
just
been walking or you know six hours
and the sleep that i got saturday with
stuff was just
really really
refreshing man good refreshing
you know we're talking about baseball
they trying to make baseball uh
faster
if they what they do to make boxing safe
for two two minute rounds or or what
nobody you know they ride at the pads
and everything and you don't want to
wear a [__] helmet in there like if
you saw a kid with a helmet and a bike
you'd be like hey hold the [__]
helmet no you know what it's just one of
like i said how do you make how do you
make cliff diving safer how do you make
downhill some things just are just
inherently
dangerous dangerous and that's why
people pay good money and they make
millions of dollars to do it and i'm not
saying it it's the price of doing
business because it's not
because you're talking about a human
life
but everybody that fights knows what the
end result you can literally go into
that ring and come out a different
person
and like we just talked about guys that
take really savage beatings and they're
never the same again and sometimes
one of my favorite fighters of all time
sure yeah i mean
right i mean the school when his
original nickname was schoolboy bobby
chicon
i mean he was you guys from the same
area you know you know who were the
greats that came out of san fernando
gary matthews yeah baseball player uh
richie valens
uh
bobby shaquan
and there's another guy right here
charles white charles white usc
and the little [__] boy that would
hit lemons in the backyard and jack off
every [__] a lot of mother mexican
magazine george lopez
had those calendars where you can lift
the film up
they were naked underneath uh
[Laughter]
look like old dog ears so yeah like oh
[__]
you know a sock with some money in it um
now when you get older and you're 60
you're shooting pool with a rope
yeah i'm you know
[Laughter]
if it wants it i do it i don't know i
don't tell it it tells me the all right
so so
uh boxing yes okay so stevie cruz and i
saw dude and i was with the
i was in corpus christi there was a guy
that was a fighter i took the [__]
forget this before guys i was with
selena's dad and he was in the
i don't remember man i mean texas is
such a hotbed for bob he was married and
and
i'm trying to jessica jesse benavides he
was from corpus christi texas former uh
national amateur champion i think he was
he was an older dude man um older than
you
what i mean older than you i mean it's
not that [__] old
let me see if i can find out everybody
the [__] that gil's older than everybody
[__] walt disney and guilford
graduated they say [__] a year in high
school
oh so what else we're talking about how
long did we talk about boxing for half
hour he graduated i got myself we didn't
even get to uh oscar
when he gave us kovitz
um he was on the show just for just
before he testified covet oh yeah so i
was weak so we were i was in training
camp with him i'm wrapping his hands
every day
eric gomez from golden boy his brother
hoel i'm wrapping his hands he was going
to fight beto belfort you know and
people are like when when oscar tests
deposit for kobe like oh he's faking it
i'm like no you know what i got covert
too
i'm glad that he didn't fight that dude
yeah i think in his heart of hearts you
know everybody has their time
you know vito belfort's a big strong guy
he fought holyfield he knocked holyfield
out in about 14 seconds and only phil
you know they're not they're not
firefighters but you know well he's like
he's a ufc world champion he knows how
to fight
would you walk into a [__] wood chip
or you're like [__] no eh no that dude
that dude knows how to fight he could he
just [__] steer you like that
he may not be able to out box oscar for
12 rounds in oscar's prime but in one of
these kind of fights with two minute
rounds you know
smaller ring
everybody's a little bit older yeah it's
it's um but i just took it would you
rather fight in a liquor store or in the
park in a liquor store if it's in belle
garden that's what i'm saying i think
you want to fight inside the story
therefore five [__] that are
outside
they'll find something to hit you with
yeah like the frito lays the rack [__]
iraq the uh the herald examiner have
those out there yeah the herald examiner
yeah
all right uh
what are we talking about we talked
about boxing um
no we stopped talking about boxing yeah
so so but
when they found out see you know now
they fight in there and the t-mobile
whatever [__] my mother
well look at now what you're gonna call
it staple center is the crypto
i mean to me that's kobe's house man
that's to me that's always going to be
staples center man
it's like changing the name of madison
square garden what if they i don't know
if they called it you know the name of
it it's madison square garden isn't the
forum the kia forum now
is that always going to be the fabulous
forum to all you guys yeah you think a
magazine was a great western
foreign great western was a bank yeah
and they said everybody got their
[__] money taken but they said greg
fights the name
i went sunday i went to sunday fights
in the early 80s and uh i saw the cast
of taxi was there you know because tony
danzano
and then uh we were driving down uh uh
manchester uh were you famous then or no
no and so they didn't want to say hi to
you or nothing no no i was in the thing
and then i was if i was in the 80s and
then we saw chick hearn driving down the
uh he was in the toyota you used to do
horses and we were [__] yelling at
him until he finally went
so we were quiet
i got pickpocketed at the forum
from the front of the back yeah from
from behind
took my id card
and you know some guy was trying to buy
beer with your picture [__] you know
back then you had to fill out a bunch of
paperwork i was a new i was a rookie and
you had to fill out a bunch of paperwork
i lost my badge you know i got big butt
as soon as i caught it filled all the
all the [__] that there were there they
laughed at you two days later they found
it they i didn't no but somebody found
out somebody found it it i had been
pickpocketed they knew they had
uh pickpockets working there i would
have used i went to see the harlem
globetrotters
do you think it was one of them no
my badge ended up in the
[__] metallurgy
they found it they didn't want the
badges threw it away
threw in the trash can can i tell you
that
there's a mountain rush more of people
that i've met
meadowlark lemon was one of the
one of the greatest people i've ever met
and you need to watch me growing up oh i
met him oh yeah
tony larussa introduced me to him i
missed him like he was [__] metal you
think of all the people that he
entertained over the years all over the
world that he brought happiness thank
you sure
all right uh
one of them was a skywalker and conduct
another one worked the night stalker
same thing right yeah
what about the what about the the what
about the serial killers that are still
out there they're still there's
they can't know how many active but
there's a lot of hundreds of cases that
are multiple
murders that are still in different
different different pockets in different
regions you're always going to have
serial killers working
they did some research and gill would
probably know more about this in the 70s
and early 80s in l.a l.a had a lot of
serial killers working they really did i
just spoke with a guy
earlier this year the one that broke the
did the dna on the uh golden state
killer yes
uh paul and i i apologize again i forget
paul what's his last name paul holtz i
was with him uh back at crime con i
didn't know that [__] dude's name and
uh so i
the day before i talked to paul i'm
talking to some lady over there and she
says there are no more serial killer i
said no
you know you're kidding yourself you
think there's no more serial killer
there's that stupid ass lady that said
that i don't even know her name and i'm
glad i don't but she said there are no
more she's do you really i said
certainly there are they just haven't
been detained well i think when people
think of serial killers they're thinking
of people that kill 70 or 80 people i
just recently concluded a case that i
worked with lapd of a serial killer we
just he just he gets sentenced in a
couple of weeks he was actually out of
san fernando i don't even know if you
remember the guy that was killing people
with a shotgun shot some dogs about
seven or eight years ago he went on like
a two or three day killing spree i mean
you don't you don't really need to be
ted bundy to be a serial killer sure
there's a lot of different a lot of
different factors that come into that
three or more and it's and the next day
in the new york post
paul's
gave a statement he believes there's
that up to as many as 2 000 serial
killers in the united states still
working today
you know we come up with
you know
new technology we come up with new ways
to work them
well the guys on the other side are
studying ways yeah to beat the new
technology and beat the way we're
working 100
100 you know so they just have to
understand that
the uh how did they catch the uh that
guy the quizzing golden state killer
through familiar dna
i mean that was many many years later
right yeah
by the time they end up catching up with
the guy right he was already in his
seventh yeah yeah he's an old man
matter of fact first time he made a
court appearance he's in a wheelchair
you know and then my wife said look at
that just for sure look at him because
he was
at a
you'd stop killing for many many years
um we don't have the uh you know there's
dudes that are sitting on death row um
we used to put people to death right
yeah
it wasn't that frequent
but you know now there's a moratorium on
that stuff so no you got guys on death
is it based on the governor is it based
on just california law
different states have is it federal
absolutely if you if you go to death row
in like florida georgia or texas they'll
[__] your appeals process is over in
about four and a half weeks
they talk about the last meal they're
really giving you your last meal i mean
california it even if they when they
were doing it it's you're talking i
think anybody ever asked for panocha is
the last man
would they do it
would they do it and say hey sir would
you like some lobster or prime rib or no
i don't know i'll give you just give me
a [__]
old-school one
he didn't go to the neighborhood
like one that looks like like a pastrami
sandwich from the hat
oh those are good
if she comes with that yellow wrap paper
and just yeah that's when you know
you're getting that so who who um
who would just who would be the one to
say
the governor
he's the one to put a moratorium yeah i
think the governor is the one to be able
to do that he was in favor of the death
penalty i don't think this particular
governor did this governor he he said he
came right out right after he got
elected he said i know the people the
state of california
voted to enact reenact the death penalty
he said but it goes against my
conscience and i can't do it so as so
long as i'm governor
nobody will die as a result of this but
don't you have to do the will of the
people or the governor can also proceed
he can save you from being killed but
yeah exactly i guess he can say who who
kind of can't you just well i think in
the end the governor is the one that has
to sign off on it at the end yeah
when all your appeals are exhausted and
if they're not going to sign off on it
so
are we still executing people in this
country every day or once in a while you
don't i think it's i think it's the same
country we are yeah i think in some
states i think in kansas and texas and
georgia florida florida florida
i mean
florida you're really you really got the
death penalty it ain't like california
where you could oh i'm gonna still live
25 years right
i think yeah it's a little bit uh i mean
i don't know man it's hard to say
because you know what steve cooley was
the uh when he was a d.a he tried to
help out get legislation to cut that
appeals process
down you know limit it right with the
amount of years it would take to get it
done
27 states still haven't oh yeah
now whether all 27 are actually
active in the process i don't think so
no
there's some heinous [__] on
death row no let him go
let him go let god sort them out there
you go
how about they do like they do the cats
they put them in a bag and put them in
the [__] river after the solid that
they take one
take them swimming with little [__]
things around their ankles
actual real cats but yeah with cats
but i mean it's just there's no
deterrent to
there's no deterrent to crime i mean
well it's like when you go to other
countries like iran you get caught
stealing they cut your hand off so they
know they already know if you're a
repeat offender right right
hey i've never done this before
when i was gone what happened to your
hand
wait i had an industrial accident what
were you doing with i i look at that
lady get dressed the [__] my mother took
your [__]
i'm keeping an eye out for her you know
uh um
how did hey what what what uh
branch of the military were you air
force
so gill's you were army right
told me that was for dudes that can't
become a mailman
you know i saw gill's face because i've
known him
he was trying to be nice gotta be a
[__] member i didn't go to the
[__] air force [__] you guys it says
george was part of the kiss army right
that's not that that's not so you know
what what was uh was your father what
what military experience i was a vietnam
veteran in the navy
they used to uh god bless you those uh
are you still alive yeah my dad is 75 my
parents are big fans of yours i don't
here's to it rudy and mary rodriguez all
right
all right um thank you for your service
rudy and the planes that used to fly low
in the jungle uh-huh uh he was in
vietnam there and my grandfather was in
the pacific in world war ii oh funny
story my grandpa's name is joe rodriguez
fruit picker my grandpa worked all the
fields i come from very very humble
beginnings fruit pickers my grandpa gets
drafted because they didn't give him a
choice what does humble beginnings mean
poor i mean
poor but people say a couple huddle
because you [__] fall right no my
grandpa used to pick strawberries yeah
just like when i first told my dad i
wanted a box so what do you want to box
nectarine beaches gloves what do you
want
so my grandfather's the only there's
only two mexican guys in the whole radar
unit in his unit in the pacific and they
would go out to those islands where all
the japanese were they'd have to set up
communications it was dangerous
his name is joe rodriguez the only other
mexican in the whole battalion the only
other mexican is named joe rodriguez
also and they're both from fresno and
they didn't know each other wow yeah wow
that's amazing yeah so my my daughter
was in the military my brother's uh son
jacob my nephew was in afghanistan so we
have four jet proud four generations of
the military in my family
so uh god bless you very much
sure and of course i was in the in the
air force i don't know if that counts
and george is in the kiss army right
that's right yeah with a comic with real
bloody you know i had uh as a result and
i've got photo i'll show you later
do you ever have nightmares when you
were in vietnam i used to have more i
still have them occasionally you get
them if you go to panda express you have
your chinese food you wake up
you know i'm just learning now can i
talk to my mom a little bit about it
yeah
my dad i didn't know this and i think my
parents had me young they had me 18 19
years old so when i was 10 11 my parents
were only 27 28 years old i didn't know
that